the submersible missing somewhere near
the wreck of the Titanic with we
understand five people on board among
them British billionaire Hamish Harding
who was one of the mission Specialists
we understand Harding is a
record-breaking adventurer who went to
the South Pole with former astral Buzz
Aldrin back in 2016 and into space on
board blue origins new Shepherd rocket
just last year well I'm joined Now by
yannica Mickelson a Norwegian Explorer
and a friend of Hamish Harding thank you
so much for joining us here on Sky News
at such a worrying time for anyone that
knows Hamish and the other four on board
perhaps you could just give us an idea
as to how Hamish Harding came to be on
board this submersible
hey Mrs he's through and through an
Explorer
um I I don't know how he came to come on
board all of a sudden he just texted me
and said I'm going to the Titanic I'm
used to Hamish doing uh elaborate
Expeditions I mean suddenly he's in
space suddenly he's at the South Pole
suddenly he's at the Mariana Trench it
does take quite a bit of preparation for
these Expeditions but we sort of
considered a Titanic to be one of the
easier
Expeditions as Hamish has already flown
to space and he has already Dove down to
the Mariana Trench which is an
eight-hour dive to reach a bottom of
planet Earth
when we talk about you know Subs we
think about submarines we talk about
submariners those who have dedicated
their lives to going to the depths of
the ocean and the years of training that
comes with that we talk about explorers
and adventurers yes you have experience
as by the sounds of it Hamish did you
know going into space uh going to the
polls um
but do you think there's adequate
preparation amongst those that we
understand to be on board for if
something goes wrong talk to you about
what kind of training Hamish may have
had for something like that because he
will have understood the risks but I
would imagine it's something you never
think you will face
I think it's important to understand
that this is this isn't just a joyride
for billionaires it is scientific
research being performed on board these
Expeditions and such expensive
Expeditions do rely on people such as
Hamas who who are willing to sponsor the
Expedition but also take the risk and
take their lives into their own hands
there is a lot of training behind such
Expeditions we've already had heavy
training for uh the dive down to the
Mariana Trench with Victor visco who has
co-pilot
um I think it's important as an explorer
to be calm and collected I used Hamish
as an inspiration but also as my mentor
when we run into trouble when our
airplane froze as we were
circumnavigating Earth and flying over
the South's pole we had to keep calm and
collected so that we could reach the
nearest airport which was Puntarenas
um yeah okay you've experienced deep
diving yourself so you'll have some idea
of what it's like to be in the kind of
equipment we just saw on our screen
there in this submersible which is so
small I mean it's unfathomable to most
people watching this afternoon the idea
of going into something like this to go
so far away beneath the surface of the
ocean give us some kind of idea of what
it's like
I think most people who start scuba
diving or even just free diving can
easily get down to about 10 meters which
is one bar of atmosphere when you get
down to where the Titanic is this is 3
800 meters the body would experience 400
times that pressure
that is the sort of pressure and there's
no chance you could survive humans are
not supposed to be at that sort of depth
it's it's an impossible feat actually
I I can tell this is
difficult for you to talk about as you
know we look at these images I mean it's
such a small craft with five people on
board and they have been missing
for some time now but let's you know try
and look at the positives of the
situation in terms of as you said you
know the headlines will say these are
adventurers these are billionaires on
board but they come with a wealth of
experience
that that kind of wealth can afford
they're doing it for scientific purposes
they're doing it for philanthropy all
sorts of you know reasons that aren't
just as you said some kind of Joyride
so presumably there are Level heads on
board that sub
scribe
yeah yeah talk to me about it talk to me
about Hamish give us an idea of the kind
of competence and the kind of man he is
that that will guide him through this
Hamish will definitely be an important
asset to the team I have no doubt that
he will be calm and collected and he
will go through the emergency procedures
and checklists together with a pilot and
captain of the submersible and he will
also be a good
um inspiration to the rest of the team
to keep calm and collected as well I
really believe that Hamish is the one
who can also help lead this team because
he has been in tricky situations in the
past on expeditions
uh yanica when this reaches a conclusion
whatever that may be and you know as we
said we are looking for the positives in
this at the moment we haven't had news
just yet so we're very much keeping an
open mind as to what is going on as that
search and rescue mission continues but
in terms of the kind of
safety and regulations that are in place
with these kind of
expeditions do you think there are going
to be questions to ask about that
because we've had a look at you know the
submersible in a bit of detail since
this news emerged and it seems quite
rudimentary for something that is as you
said dangerous is there enough safety
and regulation in place when it comes to
these kinds of expeditions do you think
you're putting your life in their hands
I think all Expeditions come with a uh
with a higher risk factor there isn't
much left on planet Earth that hasn't
been achieved that's already been
achieved and if it was easy it would
have been done already Hamish knows that
he goes into every single Expedition
with a high level of risk and I do
believe that his training will serve him
well because he is a seasoned pilot and
he has proven his durability by flying
into space and also diving down to
Mariana Trench and also expedition to
the South Pole I have full faith in
Hamish as a valuable crew member here
I am terrified
if they are stuck at the bottom of the
ocean with 96 hours of air and not able
to get back to the surface this is what
I fear the most